welcome to the final episode of this
season's wind down today we are joined
by the incredible Amanda steel displays
Tiffany she'll be helping us break down
tonight's episode low key blow a huge
part of the episode is dealing with
unifying Tiffany why do you guys feel it
was important for us to sort of tackle
Tiffany storyline evolving around
postpartum depression we wanted to
depict this because you know it's
commonplace and we wanted to show this
this struggle and it just felt like this
was the natural opportunity to just
showcase this Tiffany's the only mother
the only married one out of our group of
friends and she already started to feel
isolated in a way and so unfortunately
this this just added to her burden I
think too and also kind of like
solidified herself as like the strong
one like even though she alluded to like
things with Derek it's never like being
put in her girl's laps and so I think
that also just reflects the realities of
life you know and out of strong mind but
not necessarily in a healthy mind um so
we know how to muscle through and like
that's not gonna break me and that's not
goal hurt me like but it's like okay but
are you really dealing with it or are
you just like suppressing sadness but
that's that character right she says
yeah like my hair is know me together I
mean I even may look at conscious
decisions over the course of the season
like let my nails be less than done um
so that by pan like she doesn't even
have a manicure which for Tiffany that's
unlike you've never seen Tiffany without
this happening but like I think a lot of
women can relate to like something that
mine are actually being very indicative
of like them falling apart right now
because a lot of times would be those
little things yeah you just know or like
oh she's together and I think that was
another factor too because yes Tiffany
is going through this thing but we also
wanted it to serve as a metaphor for her
actual friends missing out like her
actual friends aren't noticing that
she's falling apart
and that is also indicative of the
friendship that they have with each
other they're not new you wanna know
their who was
Derek that's what's great I think at the
door when you guys have that moment
together where you've never led there
exceed the other side of that right and
I think even not waiting to answer the
door right how do I face this man who I
typically am together for I don't want
him to really see me like this because
what does that mean you know how will he
see me now going forward it still gives
me chills thinking about it because it
was so real about a husband and wife who
do need to see each other but it's it's
scary because baby
[Laughter]
you know we discuss in the room was from
a very early standpoint was wanting to
tackle this topic for Tiffany this year
so I would love to talk about how
postpartum depression is rarely really
portrayed accurately on TV especially
with black when it is portrayed we talk
about that a lot in the room I remember
to a point that we were talking about
debating like what's the most real
version of what she would be wearing how
you would find her what she would do
hashey Eve I mean we got very meticulous
about this because we wanted it to feel
very real yeah you talked about your
news I mean I think the hardest thing
was gonna be just figuring out an
authentic place to tap into that could
get me for the same feeling of emptiness
and confusion that you would be at if
this was you know your actual reality
speaking of pregnancy there's a big drop
in Laurens getting condole aprenden how
do you think ISA feels about that and
she Lawrence's relationship possibly
moving forward it taints him in a very
real way I say that
to me if I'm interested in a man and he
has a child with someone else but me it
robs you of that moment hmm and that's
my mind I feel like they've lost a
milestone we've seen them to finale
like when she pictured hanging back
horns having a baby together is the
first thing so now she owns on the moon
she doesn't have the firstborn he's
sharing that moment with someone else
someone who he's not with and they just
recommitted so there's things to discuss
like how active he wants to be in it in
this child's life he's not active then
he's kind of not [ __ ] right so you're
like a hunting girlfriend if can can use
them candle too because you are already
friends so meanly thank you so much for
joining us for the wine downs this
season we really hope you enjoyed
watching this season as much as we love
making it Cheers
you